si mal à votre témoignage nous allons
partir à la bourse et retrouver jean
leber parce qu'il se passe des choses
curieuses à la bourse aujourd'hui
disons que c'est peut-être la fin d'une
époque regard des gens je prends je
prends williams 1 je prends inhabituelle
puisque c'est la première fois et la
dernière fois que je fais cette
intervention appuyée sur la corbeille
c'était un lieu réservé aux
professionnels aux agents de change
je suis appuyé sur cette balustrade en
forme de cercle recouverte de velours
rouge avec en son centre un tas de sable
destiné à recueillir les mégots des
agents de change
en 1774 un arrêt royal avait créé un
endroit spécialement réservé aux agents
de change afin de les isoler du public
en 1827 avec l'installation de la bourse
dans les murs du palais brogniart la
corbeille avait servi à délimiter pour
la première fois cet endroit a réservé
la rue royale stipulait que les
cotations devait se faire en un même
lieu et à la criée afin d'assurer la
transparence des cotations
c'est ce que faisaient les agents de
change ces officiers ministériels depuis
plus de 200 ans
définitivement une page est tournée
mercredi ils et elles ont disparu
la corbeille sera devenu un objet de
musée et aura fait place aux terminaux
d'ordinateurs la criée aura cédé sa
place au système de cotation continue
assistée par ordinateur la grande
révolution c'est la délocalisation des
cotations
il y aura toujours une criée mais le
plus en plus de valeur seront cotés en
continu
il y à ce jour 68 valeur d'un inscrits
sur le marché continue aujourd'hui la
bourse donne un coup de chapeau à
l'ancêtre qui disparaît l'indicateur de
tendance monte d'un demi pour cent sur
le tableau des cotations l'électronique
et l'informatique nous ont sélectionné
les 15 plus fortes hausses
pour les privatiser paribas et à 462
francs inchangé par rapport à hier saint
gobain 20e vient d'être cotée à 450 de
francs et pour l'instant il y à une
offre sur le ccf à 151 francs sur le
marché des devises peu de changements le
dollar remonte de 3 centimes à 6 francs
14h30 le deutschmark est à 3 francs 32 à
30 la livre sterling à 988 25 l'écu à 6
francs 92 sur le marché de l'or le
lingot d'un kilo à 88 mille francs à
gagner 150 francs et à 517 prend le
napoléon a gagné 4 ans voilà où il ya
une séance un petit peu particulière qui
laisse les agents de change avec une
larme au coin de l'oeil
merci jean s'est fait voler du